hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well you've thought
about this question what is happiness I
suppose if I'm going to ask a question
you thought about this many times in
your life and you probably didn't do it
you know along the Aristotle or in
exactly the same way that aerosol did
you probably focused more on particular
things what's going to make me happy in
this situation you've deferred things
off to a certain point you've all got
some sort of an imaginary thing if I
just get this on me how it will be so
happy to graduate and then when you get
the graduation of you life well what now
you know mayor your job I'll be so happy
if I get a job then you get the job and
be like yeah now well you can keep on
asking this your whole life it would be
useful to have some sort of conception
to aim it because you you do always
pursue happiness under one guys or
another aerosol defense so it'd be
better to get it get it right from the
start
otherwise you might
life pursuing the wrong things or making
the wrong choices so what are the
different contenders well you know let's
start with something really basic a lot
of people think that happiness as well
don't think if I just win the lottery I
will be happy a lot of people think that
don't they it's one of the great
motivators for buying lottery tickets
you know there's probably better ways to
try to pursue wealth the lottery we've
talked about this before some of you are
doing very rational things right now in
order to try to pursue all Aristotle by
the way does not feel awful is a bad
thing he's not you know saying that rich
people are bad or money is the root of
all evil
actually it's like st. Paul didn't even
say money is the root of all evil is it
love only right money itself is is what
what's up
it is great day yeah yeah it's nice to
have why is it nice to have them I mean
you know we've done this before right
take out these dollar bills today I
happen to have four of them which is
almost enough to like you know get you a
meal in the cafeteria so they sound
really nice no I there's better sounding
things Oh feels so good
no there's nicer feeling things right
like somebody said who is it that you
build a house of money or you could put
in to use it for installation later yeah
you're not going to get much insulation
on this but I suppose if you get a lot
these probably be cheaper to buy
insulation there's not a lot you can get
out of this by itself I mean you know if
I'm lonely we can look at George always
looking back at me now I don't feel so
alone I'd be nuts all right what is this
good for like this for box not very much
but I mean personally I think that's
good to have for a couple different
reasons people got money if you have it
like that says something about you um
you know they're having money a
successful kind of thing yeah the sign
of success yeah and then I mean just a
habit itself that you've been buying
things that you desire or want exactly
and like the way that I kind of view
this just because I have money to buy
something it just because I have it
doesn't necessarily you know I need to
spend it either that's true and if you
have that attitude you'll probably hold
on to that means that if you buy
everything then you immediately desire
especially a lot of people are going to
get it credit cards because you can
actually buy money that doesn't even
exist yet
that gets you know created economy by
your your reactions yeah money is good
for buying other things so I mean we'll
come back to this that this is not going
to be the best answer to you know what
is happiness the nearest level points
out the life that's devoted to money
making is not really a happy life in
part because you're always you know
having to it to work you're always
having to subscribe you're not actually
getting to enjoy the things that you're
looking for for the money to buy it yeah
a lot of people make bad choices you
know we come to a junction with after
choose money do I do I do it will caulk
it will make me more money or eliminate
losses or do I do what's good for the
relationship
you know sometimes you have to choose
between these two guys right and if you
always say money that's going to be a
fairly lonely life after a while what
are other things that people want you
talked about success Aristotle talks
about honor and by this term think of
this as including respect looking like
successful people looking up to you and
a lot of people are motivated by this
right what will the neighbors think is
kind of a trivial way of talking about
this keeping up appearances
don't people spend a lot of their lives
we're into but by these sorts of things
worrying about what other people think
now Aristotle says you know if you're
really reaction about this you should
actually think about who you want to
honor you are you going to place
yourself at the mercy of everybody not
everybody's going to like you right I
think you've all experienced them
there's always gonna be somebody who's a
jerk that doesn't like you even if
you're nice yeah and if you start being
successful
there'll be somebody to the track no
matter what you do that's good somebody
will complain about it sooner or later
but who do you pay attention to people
that you admire people that you look at
people that you would like to be honored
by but now notice Aristotle says this is
a little bit dependent isn't it it has
less to do with you and more to do with
the position that you're in
and the other
kind of you know giving things in your
direction praise esteem you know
whatever happens to be mentioning you on
Facebook liking your posts
it could be trivial stuff like that so
there's something missing here too but
that's that's aerosol makes the higher
goal higher than just well what else
talk about another wonder right yeah
think about all the different kinds of
pleasures that we want on life
I don't want another plus in life I you
know there's a lot of things I like I
like why I like some pleasures I can't
have it or I can't so you know can't
smoke anymore we're not supposed to but
I like cigars and shouldn't eat as much
as I do you know certainly not the rich
foods that I do but I love to cook and I
love to eat the stuff that I cook and
I'd love to do it with people that I
like and that's all pleasure right maybe
there's some pain and burn your hand on
the stove but for the most part its
pleasure conversation company that can
be pleasure watching a movie another
kind of pleasure and you could set up
your life to be fundamentally oriented
towards enjoying pleasure Aristotle says
yeah you can as a matter of fact many
people do see that as the good thing to
do and even some of the people who are
like you know in the top notch people
who are looked up to they live lives
like that I mean you can go on TV
nowadays and you can see these celebrity
houses where they have all sorts of
crazy fixtures and and amazing baths
that you you know who knows what sort of
you know pleasure you get out of having
a gold bath apparently some sort of
pleasure it must be better than you know
a bath somehow I don't
I don't know but you get the idea and
think about all the different pleasures
that are offered to you or cater to if
you have a ball to purchase them in our
society we live in one of the most if
you want it to be hedonistic aliy
oriented societies that's ever existed
and you can talk about ancient Rome or
you know some of these other things but
not nothing compared to us you know I
mean think about you can walk into the
Student Center how many different
flavors of gum do you think they have
flavors of God
hmm I have no idea 23 himself gum you
don't apparently President Mary like
stuff on his first ever don't go okay
this is a bad example so if you went
across the street that you wanted like
all right his first his first day was
easier use the seven to go
that was a bandit oh that's interesting
that'd be somebody who's got some real
power there so nobody nobody chews gum
on campus you can't buy it on we're good
well do we have all these different
kinds of fire and you can you can focus
your life on that you can when you get
to those critical junctures you can say
well they're plugging do I take the job
that's going to be in 80 hours a week or
do I you know do something that's going
to be more relaxing for me and allow me
to watch the game with to you know spend
time outside that's
choose one or the other right and how
you pursue pleasure is going to be how
you were into your life Aristotle thinks
there's something lacking here though he
calls this a kind of you know
animalistic life it's not realizing
what's best in us
it is fun it feels good but there's
something distinctively human that gets
left out of the process is you know how
many dogs are like this what a dog alone
put it in a nice environment it'll enjoy
itself all day why it won't worry about
anything else you want to just live like
that or is there something more that you
you want well I mean if you want honor
that's already going just beyond
pleasure there's other possibilities to
talks about a pal also good thing to
write when you don't have it you feel
that you really want it talks about the
sick person saying happiness is being
healthy that's not everything
either is just to be healthy it's a good
thing this is not as completed a good as
we're as we're looking for so what else
could there possibly be well I'm going
to cut to the chase because if you do
not have that much time
Aristotle talks in terms to uh virtue
and then he talks about wisdom and I'm
actually gonna skip talking about wisdom
knowledge or any of those sorts of
things but he does actually lay out what
he calls the contemplative life as
opposed to the active life and the
contemplative life is a life in pursuit
of wisdom and I'm willing to bet that
some of you even though you're not
studying philosophy or on a track or
that's actually what your your life is
oriented about it's not actually
oriented by my honor or pleasure or
wealth you actually want to learn about
things and it may not be about
philosophy it may be about something
completely different may not even be
through through books that's okay it
still might be a life pursuing wisdom
we're going to actually put that aside
because you just talk about that in
other places but I want to talk about
virtue eventually so virtue excellence
you know excellences of mine but also
excellences of character things that I
like generosity or justice or courage or
good temper or being a good friend
those are all things that Aristotle
calls virtues also also moderation
temperance - and is this enough though
aerosol says well I mean you could you
could be virtuous should be asleep all
the time we wouldn't call a person happy
one of the things that's characteristic
about virtue is that it has to express
itself if you actually have a virtuous
character you will want to naturally do
those sorts of things if you are a
courageous person will sooner or later
start seeking out situations in which
you can exercise your courage if you are
a temperate person you will want to
actually exercise temperance it doesn't
actually make much sense to talk about
person having a virtue if they don't
actually do doesn't so it's not just
virtue is virtue as an activity and
yours little system thing really
interesting if you're doing this and you
actually are virtuous it takes a while
to become virtuous let's take generosity
for example I have not always been
generous
I've been generous in some respects but
it's hard for me coming from the way I
grew up sometimes to let go of money
when I should to benefit you know people
who need requests or friends or family
members it's hard just to give instead
of you know expecting something in
return can I become more generous yeah
it's going to be a little bit painful at
first if I want to do that but
eventually will become like LEGO sets
second nature right once it does become
second nature now if it was pleasurable
to do that it becomes pleasurable to see
that
it's pleasurable to remember it to think
about the virtuous person's life is
actually a pleasant life the doctor who
actually cares about his or her patients
and who you know may work very hard to
come home very very tired at night and
may you know not working the most
lucrative practice and it's unpleasant
to be there you know feeling the
people's BS all day long they may
actually end up taking a lot of pleasure
in their work and exercise in order to
is appropriate or work Aristotle says
one other thing about happiness that I
want to get out and close it is it
enough to have virtue virtue is activity
not in his book you know why there's two
other things you need now we always said
you're going to get you're going to get
pleasure if you are virtuous out of
virtuous activity you do need some
wealth Aristotle thinks you can be
content without well if you have virtue
you might even get through really hard
times through your virtue but you're not
going to be truly happy without the
means to do or virtuous activities and
without the capacity to actually enjoy
yourself and there's also another thing
about wealth - that's important this
leads us to the second thing you need is
the virtuous person an island all by him
or herself withdrawing from everybody
else I mean you might do that if your
goal is to pursue wisdom you know
everyone else might be a distraction but
if you're morally virtuous and this is
going to be tying in with a fulfilled
life you need friends and family to
share remember how early on in the
semester I asked you as I knew every
class what are the things you really
want out of life what do you really
value
and almost all of you said friends and
family very quickly it's always happens
you just ring it aerosol would say this
is a life that actually has to be shared
with friends and family or it's not
going to be as good as it could be
you're not going to be as happy as you
would be now this provides us with an
understanding of where we want to try to
go with all of our choices our
activities Arts and Sciences our
disciplines our commitments that we make
this sort of idea would give you you
know not necessarily the roadmap or say
at least a guiding star to make the
thing you ain't